Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Es gibt übrigens keine totale Überwachung in Deutschland.
Und wir machen auch keine Podcasts.
Nee, sowas machen wir nicht. Ja, hier gibt es nichts schriftlich. Hier gibt es alles nur in Sprache und bisweilen auch in Gesang. Wir könnten ja auch mal was rappen.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, das könnten wir nicht.
Dann müssten wir sofort hier unsere Sendung einstellen. Davon sind wir weit entfernt. Weit entfernt ist auch dieses Land, davon unüberwacht zu sein. Dazu später mehr. Wir begrüßen euch jetzt hier erstmal zur, was haben wir jetzt, der 75. Ausgabe. Das ist ja auch schon wieder fast Jubiläisch.
Dreiviertelhundertste.
Ja, dann können wir jetzt so allerlei Rechnungen aufmachen. Bringt aber nichts.
Ja, aber man könnte ja schon mal ausrechnen, wann wir ungefähr die hundertste hätten.
Nein, ungefähr 25 Ausgaben.
Jaja, aber was ist die?
25 Wochen. Jetzt muss man mit dem Internet den Date-Calculator anschmeißen.
Ja, und vor allem den Calculator, dass wir öfter mal eine ausfallen lassen. Also man müsste ja…
Mal zwar unser durchschnittlicher Ausfall…
Man müsste den durchschnittlichen Wochen pro Sendung…
Den durchschnittlichen Senderhythmus.
Den durchschnittlichen Senderhythmus, ja. Also wie viele Sendungen… Echt?
Das ist ja schnell ausgerechnet. Einfach mal zu stehen. Aber wie das immer so ist, andere Dinge waren dann doch wieder ein bisschen wichtiger.
Ja, weil das ist ja eine einfache Division. Also das kann ich. Das kann ich sogar in allen Sprachen schreiben.
Feel free to volunteer.
Den durchschnittlichen Sendung…
Den Pull-Request wird gern gesehen.
Dann könnte der Vorhersagen, also dann könnte man ihm vorhersagen, wann ungefähr die hundertste Folge erreicht wird.
Ja, das könnte man in etwa…
In ungefähr dreißig Wochen ist das. Okay, also hunderteste Sendung. Freuen wir uns jetzt schon drauf. Vielleicht gibt es dann auch was anderes zu erzählen.
Ja, vielleicht gibt es auch was Gutes zu berichten. Insofern müssen wir uns jetzt aber erstmal hier mit der normalen aktuellen Nachrichtenlage beschäftigen und die ist ja etwas, naja, ein bisschen uninspiriert.
Wir sind jetzt sicher, wir haben jetzt E-Mail made in Germany.
Ich habe aufgeatmet, als ich das gelesen habe. Ich dachte mir, endlich tut jemand mal was. Endlich wird einfach da auch, ja, kommen einfach Reiter mit Fackeln in der Hand, ziehen über den Horizont, so am Hügel, stehen sie einfach breit aufgestellt und sagen, ja, die Rettung naht. E-Mail, endlich, sicher, und wir bürgen dafür mit unserer deutschen Gründlichkeit.
Was haben sie getan? Also was waren das? United Internet und Deutsche Telekom, beides übrigens auch Betreiber von D-Mail-Diensten in Deutschland.
United Internet ist auch besser bekannt als web.de und Gmx, das ist irgendwann mal da zusammengewachsen, auch wenn es mal ursprünglich als unterschiedliche Dienste gestartet ist.
Treten vor die Presse und sagen, wir machen jetzt E-Mail-Verschlüsselung. Und dann denkst du dir, wie macht ihr das noch nicht? Was sie machen ist, sie wollen jetzt anbieten, dass man seine E-Mail über einen verschlüsselten Kanal bei ihnen abholt. Und, das ist das Spannende, sie haben auch aktiviert, dass ihre Server untereinander über einen verschlüsselten Kanal sprechen. So jetzt verschlüsselter Kanal, und so klingt natürlich alles sehr spannend. Das heißt, sie machen SSL auf den Verbindungen, also das, was ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, die muss man davon ja auch nicht vergessen, die Hörer, wenn ihr auf eine Seite geht, wo ihr euch einloggt, dann ist es eigentlich ganz normal, dass da oben, sollte es normal sein, dass da oben HTTPS steht.
Also nicht auf einer beliebigen Seite, aber auf den relevanten Diensten, den etablierten großen Diensten, zumindest dann, wenn es darum geht, in irgendeiner Form deine, ich will nicht gerade Privatsphäre sagen, aber so Login-Sachen und so weiter, wenn man bei Amazon einkauft, etc., also das ist schon...
In dem Moment, wo es individuelle, wo es sensible oder einfach schon nur individuelle Daten sind, sollte das eigentlich, also es ist eigentlich selbstverständlich, dass man das macht, weil sonst ja, also in HTTP ist nicht spezifiziert, dass Kennwörter verschlüsselt übertragen werden, sondern die werden im Plaintext geschrieben und deswegen packt man SSL da drum, sodass auf dem Transportweg dann eine verschlüsselte Verbindung zwischen dem Nutzer und dem Server besteht und dass jemand, der abhört, nicht diese Daten und dieses Kennwort bekommen kann. Das gibt es seit SSL, 20 Jahre jetzt, 15 Jahre, 15, 20 Jahre ungefähr ist SSL spezifiziert und seit 1999 ist es eben auch, also SSL kann man quasi mit jeder Verbindung machen, also man kann über SSL jetzt HTTP sprechen, man kann darüber SMTP sprechen, man kann darüber IMAP sprechen und so und für IMAP ist das, glaube ich, 1999 spezifiziert worden als RFC und für SMTP 2002. Also und das Problem war also, dass man diese Protokolle, IMAP und SMTP, sind die Protokolle, über die E-Mails einmal vom Nutzer abgeholt werden und oder gesendet werden, also vom Nutzer zum E-Mail-Server und vom E-Mail-Server zum nächsten E-Mail-Server und seit, ja, Anfang 2000, also seit über einer Dekade, seit über zehn Jahren, gibt es einen Standard, wie man diese Verbindung verschlüsselt.
Was auch nicht sonderlich schwer zu implementieren ist und was auch in allen gängigen Softwarepaketen, Out of the Box, einfach die Fähigkeit existiert. So man denn in der Lage ist, sich entsprechende Zertifikate bereitzustellen, was für Privatpersonen immer noch ein bisschen ein Problem ist, weil es ja auch mit Kosten verbunden ist.
Bei Mail nicht. Bei Mail wird das häufig ohne CA gemacht, also da wird einfach eins hingeworfen. So machen wir das zumindest häufig. Du nimmst einfach ein Zertifikat und dein Mail-Klient pint das.
Die werden sicherlich mit CA dahinter.
Weil dein Mail-Klient das meldet, wenn sich das Zertifikat ändert. Also du sagst einmal, ich traue den. Genau, das ist eigentlich eine sinnvolle Methode, mit Zertifikaten umzugehen. Weil dann merkst du wenigstens, wenn es sich ändert. Und wenn du mit einer CA arbeitest, kann ja dann trotzdem der BND, weil der ist... Okay, gehen wir jetzt nicht in Detail.
Okay, da können wir sicherlich irgendwann noch mal zu gegebener Zeit aufgehen. Aber um es vielleicht noch mal kurz etwas griffiger zusammenzufassen. Bisher war es so, dass die deutschen großen E-Mail-Provider offensichtlich die E-Mails, die zwischen ihnen hin und her gehen, nicht auf verschlüsselten Wege übertragen haben. Und das ist eigentlich ein Skandal. Das ist ein Riesenskandal. Das ist eigentlich ein Skandal. Und alles, was sie jetzt bekannt gegeben haben, ist, dass bevor es einer merkt, dass sie das Ganze ändern und wo wir gerade mal dabei sind, machen sie auch noch eine dicke Pressemitteilung raus und behaupten, es hätte irgendetwas mit Verschlüsselung der E-Mails zu tun.
Das ist nicht der Fall.
Es werden nicht die E-Mails verschlüsselt, sondern es wird die Übertragung unverschlüsselter E-Mails verschlüsselt. Am Ende kommen sie immer noch unverschlüsselt an, da sind auch die Zugriffspunkte für Behörden. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo jemand meint, da lawful Interception betreiben zu müssen, also wo irgendwelche Dienste, Polizei, was auch immer, auf welcher Gerichtsentscheidung auch immer, der Meinung ist, es wäre jetzt mal statthaft, auf diese E-Mails zuzugreifen, liegen sie unverschlüsselt herum und lassen sich dort problemlos analysieren, auslesen. Alles, das für diesen Übertragungsweg für ein paar Zehntelsekunden, die Nachricht dann tatsächlich mal verschlüsselt wurde, hat auf diesen Endzustand keinen Einfluss.
Genau, sie schützen sich davor, dass jemand zwischen den beiden E-Mails-Servern sitzt und dann mit lauscht oder auch den persönlichen Abholvorgang, den eine Person dann vornimmt, sagen wir mal in einem WLAN, wo andere Leute mithören oder eben überhaupt von einem Internetanschluss, wo der Start anwendet.
Man kann jetzt natürlich auch sagen, dass sie das bisher nicht verschlüsselt haben. Das ist ein Skandal. Ist vielleicht ein Skandal, wird aber wahrscheinlich nicht so viele konkrete Auswirkungen gehabt haben, weil man davon ausgehen kann, dass eigentlich zwischen web.de und Telekom der Leitungsweg selbst jetzt vermutlich so zwischen der einen Firma und der anderen Firma ist. Da ist jetzt noch nicht mal ein größerer Exchange dazwischen. Also ich weiß es jetzt nicht genau.
Die müssten beide ihre Rechenzentren in Frankfurt haben.
Die peeren aber nicht über das Zick, sondern die peeren einfach direkt, das heißt, es geht tatsächlich aus dem United Internet-Netz direkt in das Telekom-Netz, das ist jetzt eine Unterstellung, die vermutlich stimmt, sodass das dann an der Stelle auch keine großen Auswirkungen gehabt hat. Nur grundsätzlich sollte man solche Dienste überhaupt gar nicht erst oder für alle möglichen Verschwindungen, die denkbar sind, aufstehen.
Das hat doch eine Auswirkung, weil wenn sie keinen Star-TLS verstehen oder damit nicht ausgehen, es gibt ja immer noch den Fall, dass eine E-Mail von einem anderen E-Mail-Server kommt, zum Beispiel von Google-Mail. Und wenn Google dann irgendwie aus den USA kommt und sagt, ich habe hier lieber einen T-Online-E-Mail-Server, hier ist eine E-Mail, und der T-Online-E-Mail-Server kann keinen TLS, dann wird sie heils.
Ich habe jetzt nur diese konkrete Verbindung zwischen diesen beiden Firmen beleuchtet, aber du hast natürlich recht. Die Mail-Server sollten grundsätzlich so aufgesetzt sein, dass sie immer Verschlüsselung machen. Ich würde sogar so weit gehen, dass man mit zunehmendem Maß, wie sie auch so aufsetzen sollte, dass man sagt, nichts anderes. Ihr dürft sie hier nur verschlüsselt abliefern und wenn ihr unverschlüsselt daherkommt, dann gibt es entsprechende Penalties, was weiß ich, so ein Greylisting, dass er dann irgendwie in fünf Stunden nochmal wieder kommen müsste oder so. Also so eine Entschleunigung auch gerade, um generell Spam zu... Ja, gut, naja, weiß ja, wie das ist, so am Ende schreien dann die Kunden, so wo ist meine E-Mail? Und dann sind wir an die Frage, wer ist schuld? Ja, das will der Support dann vielleicht auch nicht ertragen. Das sind natürlich so die grundsätzlichen Implementierungsprobleme von Verschlüsselungen und komplexer Absicherung generell. Aber um es mal kurz zu machen, diese Ankündigung war einfach eine Frechheit. Man könnte das als PR-Coup verstehen und die haben sich bestimmt auch ins Fäustchen gelacht. Die saßen da locker noch mal mit dem Glas hänkeltrocknet zusammen und haben sich gefreut, wie sie das jetzt noch mal gut gelupft haben, weil natürlich unsere Tumbe-Presse das auch einfach mal so geprintet hat.
Es ist ein völliger Skandal, dass sie es nicht gemacht haben. Und sie machen da jetzt echt noch so ein Coup daraus, eine Werbekampagne. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das Wort schreibt, aber ich weiß nicht, wie man es ausspricht. Chutzpe ist da das richtige Wort.
Die muss man erst mal haben. Die Drehscher hat immer wieder schöne Wortvorlagen.
Das musst du erst mal bringen. Hut ab. Das musst du echt erst mal bringen. Aber da sind sie ja eh nicht verlegen um solche Aktionen. Was sie jetzt übrigens auch noch machen, ist, sie weiten das ja auch aus, sagen ja, schon ab 2014 wird das ja dann auch so sein. Und dann bauen sie in die Web...
Wie ab 2014 wird das?
Ja nichts. Das ist nicht jetzt.
Also sie schaffen es erst, TLS anzukonfigurieren. 2014? Sie brauchen jetzt noch ein halbes Jahr?
Warte, ja klar, da stand ihr voll... oder nur noch so. Also sie fangen jetzt damit an, wirklich. Und was sie nämlich auch noch bauen, ist...
Sie fangen jetzt an, den Prozess einzuleiten, mit dem man beginnen kann, das umzusetzen.
Ja, ja, warte, sie wollen nämlich noch...
Also...
Ja, okay, also wird von allen kritisiert. Was sie nämlich machen wollen, ist dann auch noch das in dem Web-Interface anzeigen. Also, dass du dann, du gehst ja... www.t-online oder was?
Die E-Mail-Adresse, so grün markiert, mit grünem Häkchen.
Genau, dann kommt da noch ein grünes Häkchen dran. Damit du siehst, damit du weißt... Und das ist halt kompletter Scheiß. Also Google macht das seit jeher mit seinem G-Mail-Dienst. Es geht ja dann noch weiter. Ich mein, wir müssen jetzt nicht über die Sicherheit von diesen E-Mail-Dingern reden. Aber auf ihrem HTTPS sind es ja dann auch. Dann haben sie keine Perfect Forward Secrecy und so. Also das ist fast ohne Boden, diese E-Mail-Provider. Und jetzt haben sie was eingeschaltet, was jeder... Da steht in jedem Debian-Tutorial drin, wenn du E-Mail machst. Und jetzt machen wir noch SSL an. Aber ich glaube, das ist auch wirklich das, was ich... Das kritisiere ich an diesen Tutorials so, dass sie meistens... Und das ist ja auch richtig, vom Ansatz her, du baust das irgendwie so. Und dann kommt der Moment so, jetzt funktioniert dieses Ding. Jetzt können wir eine Test-Mail schicken. Und in dem Moment hören die meisten Leute dann auf. Dabei geht es dann halt los zu sagen, okay, jetzt machen wir noch SSL an. Jetzt konfigurieren wir das alles noch vernünftig.
Aber, ja gut... Ich würde gerne an der Stelle auch nochmal nachschieben, dass ich es grundsätzlich extrem bedauerlich finde, wie schlecht E-Mail als Basisdienst des Internets grundsätzlich funktioniert. Also an der Stelle sehe ich jetzt auch mal nicht nur ein Versagen großer Unternehmen, sondern an der Stelle sehe ich auch ein Versagen des Internets als selbstbestimmtes Gebilde. Man hatte nun wirklich genug Zeit und E-Mail ist wirklich der älteste Dienst, der wichtigste Dienst nach wie vor. Allein schon deshalb, also ich meine, selbst wenn du den ganzen Tag bei Facebook rumhängst und so weiter, wenn du dein Passwort vergessen hast, über welchen Kanal kommst du daran? E-Mail. Und an der Stelle ist E-Mail auch das Tor zur Öffnung verschlossener Türe. In dem Moment, wo du die Kontrolle über deinen E-Mail-Account hast, bist du potenziell in der Lage, Kontrolle über vergessene, verlorene oder sonst wie deaktivierte Accounts wieder zurückzubekommen. Der Trust-Level, der einer E-Mail-Adresse entgegengebracht wird im Internet, ist enorm hoch. Und andere Zugänge, die deutlich besser abgesichert sind, übernehmen diese Funktionen nie. Auf der anderen Seite ist E-Mail einfach ein unglaublich... Also es funktioniert so schlecht, wie der schlechteste Teilnehmer in diesem Netz. Und das ist wirklich hochgradig bedauerlich. Also von der Verschlüsselung nochmal ganz abgesehen. Jeder wird schon mal obskure Antworten bekommen. Ich meine, es gibt da keine definierten Fehlermeldungen. Es gibt da kein definiertes Verhalten. Es gibt auch keinerlei... Wobei, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob es das nicht gibt. Das wäre mal eine interessante Forschung. Aber ich denke, es wird Zeit für so eine Art Mindeststandard, wie ein Mailserver sich zu verhalten hat. So eine Testsuit, der ein beliebiger Mailserver standzuhalten hat. Wie er auf bestimmte Nachrichten reagiert. Wie er auf bestimmte Protokollanfragen reagiert. Wie er auf Spam, keine Ahnung, oder, sagen wir mal, schlecht authentifizierte Übertragungsanfragen reagiert. Und erst, wenn so ein Server so ein Test besteht und auch regelmäßig weiterhin besteht, darf er auch in Betrieb genommen werden.
Jetzt argumentierst du gerade für D-Mail.
Nein, das tue ich nicht. Ich rede wirklich von dem normalen, offenen Internetstandard, der einfach besser funktionieren könnte, als er es tut, weil er einfach zu nachlässig mit umgegangen wird, wie wir jetzt an diesem Beispiel auch wieder sehen.
Das auf jeden Fall. E-Mail ist ausbaufähig. Da kann man noch einiges machen.
Da geht noch was.
So haben wir jetzt ein Sicherheitsniveau, was seit über einer Dekade spezifiziert ist, was übrigens die amerikanischen Anbieter seit jeher machen. Und da ziehen sie jetzt nach. Also das ist wirklich ein... Was soll man dazu noch sagen? Ich bin basserstaunt ob dieser Schutzbe.
Ja, naja, oder sagen wir mal so, man könnte auch behaupten, wir sind auch einfach mal scheiße naiv, dass wir so etwas nicht einberechnen.
Ich habe diese Dienste nie genutzt.
Na ja, klar, aber...
Doch, ich hatte meine GMX-Adresse.
Ich denke mal, gerade im Bereich E-Mail sollte man einfach jetzt grundsätzlich noch mal ein bisschen mehr draufhauen. Ich meine, da herrschen einfach überall Probleme. Überall, nicht nur bei der Telekom und so weiter. Und diese Probleme müssen gelöst werden oder...
Selber gelöst werden?
Oder wir holen Herrn Pofalla und der erklärt einfach die Probleme für beendet. Das ist doch eigentlich auch eine interessante Methode, oder?
Also... Ich...
Heute ist Fortgesetzte Sprachlosigkeit. Heute merke ich wirklich, was Politikverdrossenheit ist. Ich bin... Wer die letzten Folgen gehört hat, hat gemerkt, dass wir da mit großem Eifer diese Sachen verfolgt haben.
Aber bei...
Also nach dieser Nummer... Ich war nie verdrossener von Politik als nach jetzt irgendwie den Dingen, den Vorkommnissen dieser Woche.
Es ist...
Ich kann mich da nicht mehr darüber erregen. Ich kann da auch nicht mehr darüber lachen. Ich kann mich da auch nicht mehr darüber ärgern. Ich kann da einfach... Also ich kann da gar nichts mehr. Dieses... Was hatte Sascha Lobo vor ein paar Wochen geschrieben? Wie er dann irgendwann beim Ekel ankommt. Und dann...
Was kommt nach dem Ekel?
Ja, das ist so... Du hast jetzt gerade dich leergekotzt. So fühle ich mich. Weißt du, du bist ein bisschen erschöpft. Denkst, ach... Egal. So jetzt ist vorbei.
Jetzt geht es einander aber auch schon wieder ein bisschen besser.
Denn noch nicht fertig. Du bist noch nicht wieder aufgestanden. Du guckst noch so in die Schüssel. Weißt du? So fühle ich mich gerade. Was ist passiert? Letzte Woche, wir hatten es ja noch besprochen, als Anne hier war, jetzt ging es langsam los. Man fragt mal beim Steinmeier nach. Weil er ja der Geheimdienstbeaufsichtiger war im Kanzleramt, bevor dann die CDU die Regierung übernommen hat. Und sagte so, und jetzt hier der Steinmeier ist nämlich an allem Schuld. Der Steinmeier ist an allem Schuld. Und dann sagt der Steinmeier ja, geh ich sofort ins parlamentarische Kontrollgremium und unterhalte mich mal mit euch. Und was machen CDU und FDP? Stimmen gegen die Vernehmung. Stimmen gegen die Vernehmung. Geben dem Mann, die reiten den irgendwie durch die Presse. Sagen, ist alles seine Schuld. Stimmen gegen die Vernehmung. Und lassen den zappeln.
Alles, was wir über die gesellschaftliche Realität wissen, haben wir aus dem Anhalter gelernt. Das ist dir klar, ne? Der Anhalter der Stigaalaxis. Da gibt es nämlich auch eine schöne Stelle mit Prag. Das ist meine Lieblingsstelle mit dem ganzen Buch. Aber eine der etwas weniger nacherzählten. Deswegen möchte ich an der Stelle noch mal drauf verweisen. Du weißt jetzt gerade wahrscheinlich nicht, was gemeint ist.
Ich ist lange her, dass ich das Buch gelesen habe.
Ja, es gibt dann so diese Stelle, wo auch größere Investigationen übernommen werden. Und alle fordern sozusagen, dass jetzt mal endlich die Wahrheit rauskommt. Und Prag wird dann irgendwie auch unter dem Einsatz von bewusstseinsverändernden Maßnahmen dazu gezwungen, irgendwie auszupacken und so. Und Prag stellt sich dann aber irgendwann hin und sagt, okay, jetzt habt ihr mich so weit, jetzt packe ich aber auch wirklich aus, jetzt erzähle ich aber auch alles. Woraufhin sie alle mit einer höllischen Angst zu tun bekommen und eine große Mauer um ihn herum bauen, damit ihm bloß keiner zuhören kann, während er dann endlich mal alles erzählt. Arthur und so weiter kommen dann irgendwie gerade in dem Moment, als er das letzte Wort gesagt hat, aber keiner hat sie irgendwie mitbekommen. So ein bisschen ist das mit diesem Steinmeier. Ach, ich soll aussagen? Könnte er haben. Moment, Moment, Moment, so war es jetzt noch nicht gemeint.
So, und ungefähr so sieht es aus. Gut, ist auch der Steinmeier. Der wollte auch nur die Gelegenheit haben, da seinen Arsch zu retten. Aber wir erinnern uns letzte Woche, was haben sie gepoltert? Rösler schrie darum, lückenlose Aufklärung wird verlangt. Steinmeier ist an allem schuld. Aber nee, wir wollen den jetzt erstmal nicht fragen, weil jetzt kommt ja der Pofalla.
Pofalla.
Den Pofalla machen.
Und Pofalla hat lückenlos aufgeklärt. Pofalla hat lückenlos aufgeklärt und sagt...
Wir sollten nochmal kurz erwähnen, wer Pofalla ist.
Pofalla... Ich hab weiss, was ich gestern gelernt habe, von Lorenz Mazat, ich denke mal, den darf ich da zitieren. Pofalla ist nämlich, dass die neue Figur die Harpe Kerkeling spielt. Irgendwann nimmt der Kerkeling die Verrückung ab und sagt, Edge, Edge, ich moderiere doch, wer denn das? Also Harpe Kerkeling in seiner Figur, Ronald Pofalla, stellt Ronald Pofalla und sagt, ja, das können wir schnell einspielen, weil das muss man echt wörtlich hören. Also er sagte...
Also seine Rolle ist Bundesminister für besondere Aufgaben, übrigens, und Chef des Bundeskanzlers. Als solcher ist er sozusagen auch der offizielle Geheimdienstkoordinator, also derjenige, der zwischen Regierung und Geheimdiensten den Kontakt hält, der quasi Nachrichten weiterleitet, der als erster zu informieren ist, die Schlüsselfigur.
Er ist der Chef von den Geheimdienstchefen. Mit dem müssen die reden. So was sagt er? Wir haben jetzt schriftlich von BND, NSA und GCHQ.
Wir haben nochmal ein Fax hingeschickt.
Und wir haben jetzt schriftlich, dass es jetzt aufgeklärt ist und dass es keinen Überwachungsskandal gibt. Und es gibt keine millionenfache Grundrechtsverletzung.
Alle halten sich an die deutschen Gesetze.
Das sind zwar Auslandsgeheimdienste, aber natürlich, wenn du so ein Auslandsgeheimdienst in den USA machst, ist ja ganz klar, dass er sich an das deutsche Recht hält.
Er hat ja auch gesagt, sie halten sich in Deutschland an die deutschen Gesetze. Reingeografisch sind sie ja auch in Deutschland, weil wir haben ja auch NSA-Stationen, nur dass es dann wiederum eine Ausnahme von dem hoheitlichen Gebiet gibt, und dann sind sie da eben wie so eine Botschaft, sind sie dann eben doch USA.
Ich glaube, wir müssen das jetzt mal doch noch kurz einspielen, weil das ist wörtlich zu fein, wie viele Ausnahmen er da macht.
Du hast ja gesagt, wir spielen das mal kurz ein, dann spiele ich das jetzt einfach mal kurz ein.
Der Vorwurf der vermeintlichen Totalausspähung in Deutschland ist nach den Angaben der NSA, des britischen Dienstes und unserer Nachrichtendienste vom Tisch. Es gibt in Deutschland keine millionenfache Grundrechtsverletzung.
Naja, also ist alles klar eigentlich.
Der Vorwurf einer vermeintlichen Überwachung ist nach den Angaben der Geheimdienste vom Tisch. Hier, wir haben einen Vorwurf an euch, dass ihr uns nämlich überwacht. Nein, er ist vom Tisch.
Eine millionenfache.
Keine millionenfache.
Jetzt bewegt es sich im Milliardenbereich oder 999.999.
Es ist genau dieses sehr, sehr spezifische, wie nennt man das, spezifische...
In Deutschland wurde nicht... Er hat nicht mit einem grünen Baseballschläger auf alle eingedroschen. Das können wir Ihnen einfach bestätigen. Da war nämlich Rosa mit blauen Punkten.
Also diese specific denial. Ich weiß nicht, was heißt, wie das auf Deutschland heißt. Suspiciously specific denial.
Also man ist sozusagen so genau, dass es dann schon wieder verdächtig ist.
Genau. Aber so stellt er sich dahin und erklärt damit die Sache für beendet. Und wunderschön sagt außerdem, außerdem geht es dann ja noch darum, dass die NSA Mobilfunkdaten vom BND bekommen hat, die dazu geeignet seien oder eigentlich auch sind, wenn, je nachdem welche Daten das waren, damit Drohnenangriffe auf Zielfällen zu fliegen.
Das war von Telefonnummern die Rede. Das wäre ja nicht ausreichend, um damit Drohnenangriffe durchzuführen.
Das ist einfach mal falsch.
Das stimmt nicht, ja. Also wenn du die Telefonnummer hast, kannst du die restliche Information...
Wenn du die Telefonnummer hast, hast du alles. Dann weißt du, welche Geräte unter dieser Telefonnummer angemeldet sind.
Kommt darauf an, ob dir das Netz gehört oder nicht. Wir haben da gestern noch kurz darüber gesprochen. Also grundsätzlich gehe ich davon aus, dass ein Geheimdienst aus einer Telefonnummer eine Lokalisation, die so genau ist, dass eine Drohne dann auch die Person trifft, auf jeden Fall machen kann. Ich weiß nur nicht, ob sie es gemacht haben.
Also technisch brauchst du dann halt eigentlich die IMSI. Also du musst halt wissen, wie das Gerät, das die Person unter dieser Telefonnummer benutzt.
IMSI ist SIM-Karte. E-Mail ist Gerät. Die wollen aber die IMSI haben.
IMSI ist die SIM-Karte.
Mobile Subscriber Identity, die ist in der SIM-Karte.
Ja, okay, ich meinte natürlich die SIM-Karte. Wie auch immer auf jeden Fall, dann weißt du auch, mit welchem Gerät da gearbeitet wird. Und das kannst du natürlich dann auch von verschiedenen Stellen aus peilen.
Also man würde glaube ich, was man macht, ist man fragt, man sagt dem Gerät über eine internationale Verbindung, ich möchte jetzt gerade eine SMS an diese Nummer schicken. Dann antwortet das HLR, Home Location Register, des Anbieters mit der LAC, also der ungefähren Region, in der sich dieses Mobiltelefon befindet. Und an das wird dann diese Nachricht geschickt. Dann weiß man schon mal grob, wo sich die Person aufhält. Das ist bei städtischen Regionen dann teilweise höher auflösend als in ländlichen Regionen. Und dann kannst du mit deiner Drohne ja schon mal in die richtige Richtung fliegen und dich da umhören. Und dann musst du eigentlich noch wahrscheinlich an den Punkt kommen, dass du das Signal dieses Mobiltelefons auch wirklich aufschnappst. Und dann kannst du das triangulieren und am Ende eine Bombe auf den Kopf.
Also ist möglich.
Ja, wenn man das so genau hat, streut man halt ein bisschen breiter.
Das ist ja auch wegen der Sicherheit, wenn es sicher sein wird, dass du getroffen hast. Okay, also der ist aber auch entkräftet. Der ist jetzt auch entkräftet, hat der Pofalla wahrscheinlich auch schriftlich. Und was er jetzt noch machen möchte, ist ein No-Spy-Abkommen. Das ist schön, das ist süß. Er möchte nämlich jetzt, die USA haben also jetzt angeboten gesagt, ey lass uns doch ein Anti-Spionage-Abkommen machen. So wir unterschreiben uns gegenseitig, dass wir uns nicht spionieren. Gegenseitig. Und der sagt ja, das war glaube ich Pofalla, der sagte, dieses Angebot könnte uns niemals gemacht werden, wenn die Aussagen der Amerikaner sich in Deutschland an Recht und Gesetz nicht tatsächlich zutreffen würden. Würden die ja niemals vorschlagen.
Die würden ja auch niemals lügen.
Die würden ja auch niemals lügen. Das ist ja ein Geheimdienst, die müssen ja Wahrheit sagen.
Nur, dass ihnen das genau gerade nachgewiesen wurde und sie es sogar haben selbst zugeben müssen, dass sie vor dem Kongress in den USA gelogen haben wie gedruckt mit all ihren Aussagen über die Überwachung. Der Typ ist natürlich auch nach wie vor im Dienst. Das ist auch alles komplett konsequenzenfrei. Von daher sind diese Geheimdienste da auch sehr offen, einfach liebige Dokumente zu unterschreiben.
Ja klar, wir können euch da so einen Fax schicken.
Was hättet ihr denn da gerne? Eine Zusicherung, dass wir nicht spionieren? Klar, dann legt er den Hörer auf, dreht sich zurück in den Raum, wo die anderen sitzen. Ich hab da grad ein Fax hingeschickt, dass wir nicht mehr spionieren. 21, 22, gelächter.
Das Schöne ist ja, so ein Abkommen ist doch das Geilste, was du als Geheimdienst haben kannst. Weil, wenn du das Abkommen hast, kannst du davon ausgehen, wenn du so lange Pofalla da sitzt, dass der auch glaubt, dass du dich daran hältst und quasi gar nicht mehr prüft. Oder ja, wie, Delay irgendwo, wie so. Woher wissen die Amis, dass der nur schon wieder wahrscheinlich aus Afghanistan? So ein Bullshit. Aber noch ganz kurz zu den Inhalten dieses Anti-Spy, No-Spy-Abkommens. Da gab es jetzt also irgendwie einen ersten Draft, wo dann gesagt wird, keine Verletzung der jeweiligen nationalen Interessen, das heißt keine Aussperrung von Regierungen, Behörden und diplomatischen Vertretungen. Schwierig, weil gerade um die diplomatische Vertretung ist ja eh alles voll mit Abhörmitteln.
Ja, es gab ja auch gerade den Bericht im Spiegel, dass ja Außenpolitik auch ganz ganz ganz oben auf der Interessenliste der NSA steht, was Europa und Deutschland im Besonderen betrifft.
Keine Aussperrung von Regierungen, Behörden und diplomatischen Vertretungen. Interessant, weil da haben wir jetzt zumindest diesen belegten Fall, dass sie das in Brüssel schon gemacht haben. Die Amerikaner, wir erinnern uns, dass sie da die Telefonanlage irgendwie gehackt haben und die Vertretungen da in Brüssel abgehört haben. War auch alles Quatsch, stimmt nicht, hat der Pofalla schriftlich. Keine gegenseitige Spionage, keine gegen die Interessen des jeweils anderen Landes gerichtete Datensammlung. Gegen die Interessen, ja, ist es auch wieder sehr schön, solange das auch im Interesse dieses Landes ist, wird es weiter gemacht. Keine wirtschaftsbezogene Aussperrung. Das heißt keine Aussperrung ökonomisch nutzbaren geistigen Eigentums und keine Verletzung des jeweiligen nationalen Rechts. Jetzt frage ich mich, woher wissen die das vorher? Das ist genauso wie bei... Naja, das ist doch ähnlich wie bei den großen Lauschangriff oder bei den Abhörmaßnahmen der Polizei, wo gesagt wird, wir dürfen keine Privatgespräche abhören. Oder die dürfen die nicht aufzeichnen oder was. Und da gibt es doch dann diesen schönen... Also erstens gibt es in Deutschland immer wieder die Fälle, dass die natürlich doch mit aufzeichnen, weil sie können es ja gar nicht unterscheiden. Sie wissen ja nicht vorher, was da jetzt besprochen wird. Und es gibt auch diese schöne Szene in dem Film Casino, glaube ich, wo die Telefonate zwischen den Gangsterbossen immer damit anfangen, dass die Frauen eine halbe Stunde über ihre Frisuren reden, bis dann irgendwann die Männer, die Gangsterbosse, dann ans Telefon gehen. Und weil sie dann halt so lange gewartet haben, bis die Abhör-Fuzzis aufgelegt haben. Das macht natürlich keiner. Quatsch. Also totaler Quatsch. Also No-Spy-Abkommen. Es geht nicht beknackter als ein No-Spy-Abkommen mit Roland Pofalla oder Ronald Pofalla. Das ist...
Man hat auch so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass sie auch so ein No-Brain-Abkommen abgeschlossen haben.
Na die sind, ich denke, relativ klar sitzen da die, sind die in diesen Gesprächen, die US-Regierung und die Bundesregierung und überlegen sich, wie sie aus dieser Nummer gemeinsam rauskommen. Ich glaube nicht, dass da irgendwo auch nur in entferntester Weise ernsthafte politische Verstimmungen sind. Ich bin relativ sicher, dass die da einfach zusammensitzen und sagen, ey, irgendwie ein paar Tode müssen wir hier alle sterben, so wie teilen wir die gut untereinander auf, damit wir möglichst schnell weitermachen können.
Wobei an der Stelle wiederum könnte der Wahlkampf natürlich etwas hinderlich sein. Grundsätzlich würde ich eher sagen, ist der Wahlkampf auch für die Aufklärung hier sehr hinderlich, weil einfach viel zu viele kurzfristige Interessen dastehen. Und man sieht ja auch schon in der Art und Weise der Auseinandersetzung, also da werden alle möglichen Winkelzüge und unlogischen Schlüsse aus der Tasche geholt, nur um möglichst schnell auf Merkel oder Steinbrück oder was auch immer irgendeine Schuld zu schieben.
Ja, dieses Umgehen mit dem Steinmeier ist ja das beste Beispiel. Das ist ja eine reine Wahlkampfsache. Also ging ja um nichts anderes. Wir packen den jetzt so voll mit Schmutz und geben ihm da nicht die Gelegenheit, überhaupt zur Stellung zu nehmen. Das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, unabhängig davon, was der Steinmeier jetzt wo gemacht hat, ist das sowas von wiederwertiges politisches Taktieren. Da fällt mir nichts mehr zu ein.
Also, kommen wir zurück zu deiner Politikverdrossenheit. Ich weiß jetzt, wie sich das anfühlt, geht mir auch ein bisschen ähnlich, muss ich sagen. Es ist schon so, dass man auch echt denkt, ey Wahlen, lass mich in Frieden. Also es ist einfach wirklich schwierig, sich hier eigentlich noch für irgendetwas zu motivieren, weil es einfach so diese klassische Zur-Schaustellung des, nein es wird sich nichts ändern, weil das nicht geht. Das ist eigentlich die Kernaussage, die hier drin steht.
Ja und auch das, also das, also ich glaube es ist, man sieht in dieser ganzen Affäre, wie tatsächlich dieses gesamte Parlaments- und Politiker- und sonst was Ding da eine Schau ist für die Zeitung. Da ändert sich nicht wirklich was. Also durch diese, es muss irgendwie Unterhaltung her, es muss den Leuten der Eindruck verschafft werden, dass es überhaupt einen politischen Diskurs gäbe. Diese Idee muss aufrechterhalten werden, sonst wären wir ja keine Demokratie oder was. Es muss da irgendwie dieses Theater geben. Es ändern sich Dinge aber überhaupt nicht. Es werden keinerlei fundamentale Fragen mehr gestellt. Es gibt eine relativ ausführliche Tradition, fast schon in den Politikwissenschaften, das alles als Postpolitik zu bezeichnen. Es gibt nicht mehr Politik, es gibt nur noch dieses Theater, was im Prinzip Verwaltung ist. Es gibt noch ein tägliches Theater der Verwaltung dessen, was der Staat ist. Es gibt aber keine Änderungen und mehr in dem, wie der Staat sich verhält.
Ja, ein schöner Text, an dem wir an der Stelle noch verweisen sollten. Zu dieser Gesamtgefühls-Gemengelage ist ein Gastbeitrag auf netzpolitik.org von Gregor Selak, den wir ja auch hier schon bei Logbuch Netzpolitik zu Gast hatten. Unter dem Titel Das Ende der Netzpolitik, in Klammern, wie wir sie kennen, spannt da wirklich einen sehr interessanten Bogen mit interessanten popkulturellen Vergleichen mit Matrix, dem Film, dem ersten Teil natürlich, wie sich durch die Geschehnisse auch Netzpolitik als solches wandelt, von einem Spatenthema zum weltpolitischen Grunddiskurs. Den Text jetzt zusammenzufassen, das wird mir auf jeden Fall misslingen. Von daher an der Stelle nur die uneingeschränkte Empfehlung, sich den doch mal durchzulesen. Das ist wirklich Literatur, die man mal sogar im gepflegten Milchcafé zu sich führen möchte.
Oder Heißgetränk eurer Wahl.
Es gab noch eine schöne Rede.
Obama.
Obama hat auch eine schöne Rede gehalten. Er hat gesagt, er wird jetzt mehr Transparenz in die Machenschaften der NSA bringen. Das hat aber nichts mit den Enthüllungen von Edward Snowden zu tun. Und er möchte also die Behörden künftig strenger kontrollieren lassen und ihre Arbeit transparenter machen. Die NSA bekommt jetzt eine Bürgerrechts- und Datenschutzabteilung. Ich bin mal gespannt, welchen...
Zeit wird's.
Ich bin mal gespannt. Da wird sich ja auch irgendwie eine schöne Figur hinbefördern. Da muss man mal gucken, welcher Bürgerrechtsaktivist oder so jetzt in diese Position kommt. Das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass man sich da einen rauskauft. Und gleichzeitig wurde dann von der NSA so ein Fact-Sheet veröffentlicht, wo sie auf vielen Seiten erklären, dass sie keine Amerikaner abhören. Das wäre sowieso das Einzige, was die USA interessiert. Und dann sagen sie, das Internet transportiert nach allgemeiner Schätzung so 1826 Petabyte pro Tag. Und die NSA hätte 1,6% davon in den Fingern. Und schaue sich davon nur 0,025% an. Also nur 0,00004% des Weltinternet-Traffics. Behaupten sie jetzt. Aber jetzt kommt der spannende Teil. Da drin steht, dass sie natürlich, das kennen wir ja, nur ausländische Zielpersonen verfolgen. Wir erinnern uns, das war ganz zu Beginn der Affäre, war schon klar, ausländische Zielpersonen bist du dann, wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit 51% ist, dass du nicht Amerikaner bist. Also ein bisschen besser als im Münzwurf. Und sie sagen, sie arbeiten mit 30 Staaten der Welt eng zusammen. Und Deutschland, jetzt kommt noch nicht der interessante Teil, Deutschland ist ja offensichtlich Teil dieser 30. Und jetzt fragt man sich, warum arbeiten die überhaupt mit Deutschland zusammen? Weil wenn der deutsche Geheimdienst keine Deutschen überwachen darf und die NSA sich daran hält, in Deutschland an das deutsche Gesetz, nämlich keine Deutschen abzuhören, dann fragt man sich, was machen die da überhaupt? Was ist Basis für diese Kooperation? Also man merkt diese, was die jetzt nur, was Obama und Pofalla da jetzt tun?
Also sie hören sie ja nicht in Deutschland ab, sie hören sie ja in den USA ab.
Ja, es ist einfach Bullshit. Es ist einfach Bullshit. Es ist einfach von vorne bis hinten Bullshit. Wofür sollten die, also du brauchst nicht mit einem Geheimdienst eines anderen Landes zu kooperieren, wenn nicht zu dem Zwecke, oder du brauchst überhaupt gar nichts in einem anderen Land zu machen, als ein Geheimdienst, wenn du dich an die Gesetze hältst. Die Idee eines Auslandsgeheimdienstes ist, dass du dich nicht an die Gesetze der anderen Länder hältst, noch nicht mal an deine eigenen, sondern dass du spionierst, du bist ein Geheimdienst. Und das ist also totaler Quatsch. Wollte ich nur noch mal festgehalten haben. Also so viel zu Obama. Was soll man da noch irgendwie? Es werden die Nebelkerzen geworfen. Das fand ich eine sehr schöne Aussage von dem Konstantin von Notz, Politiker der Grünen-Partei, und der sagte dann, ein Pofalla ist der Mindestabstand zwischen zwei Nebelkerzen. Neue Maßeinheit.
Diese 1,6 Prozent, das ist auch wieder eine geile. Ich meine, das dürfte etwa den Unterschied zwischen Text und Bildern. Also nimm einfach die Katzenfotos schon mal raus, dann bist du wahrscheinlich bei 1,6 Prozent. Mit anderen Worten, sie schauen sich alles an.
Ja, das ist noch ein wichtiger Punkt. Die großen Verhältnisse, Textbilder, Pornos.
Wenn sie hier schon mit Petabytes kommen und so weiter, da hast du einfach die Fotos, die Filme vielleicht raus. Oder manche schauen sich dann vielleicht trotzdem noch an. Davon nur 0,25 Prozent. Das ist dann halt abzüglich das Spam. Was sie im Prinzip sagen, ist, sie schauen sich alles an, was relevant ist.
Klar, vieler Traffic ist ja auch völlig redundant.
Du willst ja nicht jeden Rick Astley immer wieder komplett mitschneiden, wenn er von YouTube übertragen wird.
Den speichern wir unter Rick Astley.
Ansonsten, was die wirklich interessanten Informationen betrifft, ist die NSA auch ganz bei Rick Astley und sagt, I'm never gonna give you up.
Es ist unglaublich. Es gab noch so eine Randdebatte, so ein Teilskandal, wo dann gesagt wurde, die Telekom wertet Telefondaten aus. Und zwar haben sie wohl ein Computersystem, was irgendwie gesamten Telefonverkehr überwacht und auswertet. Und was sie damit finden, also was sie da haben, ist ein Fraud Detection System, das hat garantiert jeder Netzanbieter. Hat sowas. Die suchen halt Leute, die ihre Verträge missbrauchen, für Deals-Leistungen.
Die ihre Flat-Rates tatsächlich so ausnutzen, wie es im Vertrag steht.
Die die Flat-Rates komplett ausnutzen und nicht ewige Auslandsgespräche führen. Da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten, solche Netze, Mobilfunknetze, irgendwie zu betrügen. Und das versuchen sie natürlich zu erkennen. Sie haben allein damit 160.000 Anschlüsse aufgrund von Missbrauch gesperrt im letzten Jahr. Das ist jetzt nicht so überraschend, dass sie das machen. Natürlich können diese Systeme auch unter Umständen andere Sachen erkennen. Aber so wie ich das kenne, ist meistens das Lawful Interception-Teil nochmal woanders. Das ist nur so ein Halbskandal. Ihr kriegt ja von eurem Telefonanbieter auch den Einzelverbindungsnachweis. Also ganz klar, natürlich speichern die zu Abrechnungs- und sonstigen Zwecken irgendwie euer Telefonieverhalten für einen gewissen Zeitraum. Das ist schade, vor allem wenn man jetzt sagt, man hat eine Flatrate, würde man ja erwarten, es gibt keinen Grund mehr zu Abrechnungs-Zwecken, mein Telefonieverhalten aufzuzeichnen. Aber eben zur Verhinderung von Fraud und so machen die das. Das ist eine Tatsache, mit der man sich anfreunden muss.
Das halte ich auch für absolut legitim. Also ich meine, wenn du so ein komplexes System betreibst, dann musst du das einfach im Blick behalten. Würden sie das nicht tun und dann geht was in die Hose und du wirst dann Opfer auch so eines Betrugssystems, einfach als Kollateralschaden und dann bist du noch nicht mehr in der Lage, das auch in irgendeiner Form auszuwerten, dem nachzugehen, die Methodik als solche auch zu erkennen und das dann entsprechend auch abzustellen, dann wärst du einfach ein schlechter Debugger. Also ich meine, so geht man auch auf seinen Code, wenn man programmiert. Und so muss man natürlich auch ein komplexes System wie so ein Telefonnetzwerk auswerten. Natürlich eben dann auch unter den Aspekten Datenschutz etc., was dann anfällt etc. Aber das ist ja auch alles durchaus zu machen und leistbar. Und Anfragen von Diensten sind dann nochmal eine andere Geschichte.
Was ganz interessant ist, das habe ich vor einiger Zeit von Jacob gehört, dass es eine Firma gibt mit dem Namen M-Docs, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche. Nee, ich suche das gerade. Okay, müssen wir nochmal schauen, aber es ging da um eine israelische Firma, an die man als Telefonie-Anbieter das Billing outsourcen kann. Und die schicken dann die Telefonrechnungen für dich. Und das machen sie sehr, sehr günstig. Ich gebe das jetzt erst mal nur als Gerücht so weiter, weil ich es nicht weiter geprüft habe, wer genau mit dieser Firma auch zusammenarbeitet. Aber auch das ist echt cool. Die machen die Telefonabrechnungen für dich. Das ist gar kein Problem. Schickst du Rohdaten rüber, kriegst du die zurück. Aber wie gesagt, das jetzt als Gerücht. Also es ist nicht so toll, wenn da Telefondaten aufgezeichnet und analysiert werden. Aber ich glaube, dass das geschieht, da brauchen wir uns irgendwie auch keine Illusionen hinzugeben. In welchem Rahmen das geschieht, betrifft dann natürlich auch so Gesetzgebungen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und ähnliche Dinge. Da kommt man schon in diesen Graubereich. Aber die Tatsache selber, dass die Telekom, wie jeder andere Netzbetreiber, irgendwie ein Fraud-Detection-System unterhält, ist erstmal glaube ich nicht so der Skandal, zumal die eben noch ganz andere Sachen in ihren Schränken stehen haben, die tatsächlich dann eher ein Problem sind. Eine letzte Meldung, die es letzte Woche nicht mehr in die Sendung geschafft hat. Wir erinnern uns FinFisher, der Staatstrojaner aus dem Hause Gamma, der in den unschönen Regionen auf der Karte der Demokratie gefunden und exportiert wird, über den es jetzt einen Kaufvertrag gibt, über eine Lizenz zwischen dem Bundeskriminalamt und der Firma Elermann-Gamma. Diese ganze Sache wird hauptsächlich verfolgt in Deutschland von André Meister, dem Autor bei netzpolitik.org, der ja auch bei uns schon öfter zu Gast war. Und der schickt da ja eine Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfrage nach der anderen hin. Und jetzt hat er gesagt, er würde ja ganz gerne mal diesen Vertrag sehen. Und da wurde ihm dann geantwortet, ja, desgeheim, weil er geheim ist. Sie haben den Antrag abgelehnt mit der Begründung, eine Einsichtnahme in den Vertrag würde den Erfolg der Quellen-TKÜ gefährden, weil eben Rückschlüsse auf das Gesamtsystem Hardware, Schwachstellen und Methoden gewährt würde. Also in dem Vertrag steht offensichtlich in der Leistungsbeschreibung drin, welche Wege der Infektion möglich sind, laut dem Service-Level-Agreement. Man kann das, wie gesagt, bei den WikiLeaks-Bifights sehen, dass es mannigfache Möglichkeiten gibt, die Gamma da anbietet. Zweiter Grund, der Vertrag ist Verschlusssache nur für den Dienstgebrauch. Dritter Grund, man muss das geistige Eigentum und die Betriebs- und Geschäftsgeheimnisse der Firma Elermann schützen. Und Elermann hat auch verweigert, diesen Vertrag unter dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz offen zu legen.
Weil sie sich so viel Mühe damit gegeben haben und dann natürlich auch die Urheberrechtsansprüche drauf haben. Ja, Betriebs-
und Geschäftsgeheimnisse ist diese schöne Ausnahme. Ich glaube, § 6 Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, worunter ja dann so viele Sachen fallen. Das war ja auch etwas, vielleicht erinnerst du dich...
Bei der Maut und so.
Ja, und Dodger hatte da auch viel von erzählt, als wir über die Transparenz-Initiative in Hamburg mit ihm gesprochen haben, vor über einem Jahr oder so. Und dann haben sie zuletzt, das fand ich dann sehr geil, haben gesagt, ja, und wir haben sogar in Erwägung gezogen, einfach zu schwärzen, die schützenswerten Vertragsinhalte, aber dann bleibt eigentlich nichts mehr über. Deswegen schicken wir dir jetzt gar nichts.
Ja, der ist so geheim.
Der ist geheim, können wir dir nicht schicken.
Das geht einfach gar nicht. Ja, ich meine, wenn hier überhaupt irgendwo ein Argument zu finden ist, dann in Punkt eins. Kann ich ja sogar nachvollziehen in gewisser Hinsicht, dass so ein Vertrag so etwas macht. Allerdings, klar, schwärzen, ich finde, den Geldbetrag, den hätte man durchaus da noch stehen lassen können. Das wäre für sich genommen immer noch eine interessante Information.
Der ist ja bekannt, das waren ja wie 150.000.
Ja gut, wenn der eh bekannt ist, dann kann man ja dieses Dokument, wo der Betrag auch drauf steht, auch mal rausschicken. Dann weiß man es auch genau, ob das stimmt. Aber es ist schon bekannt, solange bis es irgendwie belegt ist.
Das ist ja sowieso noch mal so ein Trauerspiel, was da nebenbei stattfindet, dass wir eben wirklich verbriefte, verfassungswidrige Software da kaufen. Das, denke ich, muss auch echt noch mal betont werden. Es ist ganz klar, dass dieses System in Unrechtsregimen zum Einsatz kommt. Das ist belegt. Es ist ganz klar, dass dieses System nicht in Einklang mit dem grundgesetzlich verbrieften Rechten der deutschen Bevölkerung steht. Und damit wird es trotzdem ohne Probleme da weiterhin eingekauft. Das ist schon eine sehr harte Sache, wie da echt verfahren wird.
Wir prangern das an.
Wir prangern das an. Verkauft eure Exploits nicht an Gamma.
Gut, sind wir zum Ende gekommen, oder?
Wir sind zum Ende gekommen. Und ich will nur noch einen kurzen Hinweis loswerden, die unsere Debatte über das Hackercamp Oben in Holland hat dann in den Kommentaren noch eine relativ viel Resonanz bekommen. Unter anderem haben wir auch Kommentare bekommen von der Biene. Das ist die Oben-Mitorganisatorin und Fahrerin des Golfkarts auf, dass der Klebebandanschlag vorgenommen wurde. Ich denke, diese Kommentare sind auf jeden Fall für Leute, die sich jetzt für dieses Camp noch weiterhin interessieren. Einige haben ja auch kommentiert, dass sie es nicht mehr interessiert. Auf jeden Fall mal lesenswert, diese Perspektive auch mal zu sehen. Weil was vielleicht bei unserer Debatte beim letzten Mal nicht ausreichend betont wurde, ist, dass da Menschen sind, die sich eben für dieses Camp wirklich sehr, sehr viel Mühe gegeben haben. Und unabhängig davon, was da jetzt nicht gut gelaufen ist oder so, da sehr viel Herzloth reingesteckt haben.
Es ist einerseits von außen alles nicht im Detail überschaubar. Wir haben uns auch nur bestimmte Aspekte herausgegriffen, die wir eben für diskutabel hielten und auch noch finden. Und die Bewertung ist dann doch immer sehr subjektiv. Aber wer da Lust hat, da noch mit einzusteigen, das brodelt dann noch fleißig in den Kommentaren.
Das ist ein Punkt, den ich noch kurz herausnehmen möchte, was sie kritisiert ist. Da hat sie zumindest einen Punkt, über den man nachdenken könnte, dass solche Hacker-Events von irgendeiner Debatte bestimmt werden. Und nennt er Beispiele, diese rot-gelb-grünen Karten beim letzten Kongress oder irgendwelche Auseinandersetzungen über WikiLeaks und OpenLeaks beim Camp. Und ich glaube zumindest hat sie einen Punkt, dass die Szene manchmal dazu neigt, sich zum Drama neigt.
Ja, das kann gut sein.
Das hat jetzt erstmal mit den Inhalten nichts zu tun, aber die Szene neigt zum Drama und da hat sie auf jeden Fall einen Punkt mit.
Das mag sein, aber ich muss auch sagen, an der Stelle hat sich einfach auch eine Diskussion entwickelt, die meiner Meinung nach einfach überfällig war und die viel zu lange ausgesessen wurde. Und das hat sicherlich auch damit zu tun, dass es eben jetzt zu einer Eskalation gekommen ist, dass sie eben so lange einfach so nicht geführt wurde. Also gerade wenn man die Dinge dann eben auch nicht mehr angeht. Meine Hacker-Szene, wie viele andere auch, aber da ist es halt auch stark, das ist schon ein sehr debattier- und discussionsfreudiges Völkchen. Und ich finde das auch gut, weil das ist dann schon auch der Discord, der an der Stelle einfach auch walten muss, um dann einfach mal auch klar herausbilden, sich herausbilden zu lassen, was wollen wir eigentlich, was ist uns was wert, was spielt für uns hier eigentlich wirklich eine Rolle, was ist uns egal und was ist uns so wichtig, dass wir da eben auch mit dem Thema sehr sensitiv umgegangen wissen möchten. Und das hat an der Stelle einfach gefehlt, aus der deutschen Perspektive heraus.
Was folgt auf den Discord im diskordianischen Kalender?
Konfusion.
Und dann?
Dann die Beamtenherrschaft.
Also wir haben noch einiges vor uns.
Wenn wir mit dem diskordischen Zyklus jetzt anfangen, da könnte man auf den einen oder anderen guten oder schlechten Vergleich ziehen. Das machen wir jetzt aber nicht. Sondern wir sagen Tschüss und bedanken uns fürs Zuhören hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Bis nächste Woche.